los ministros de defensa de la otan se
reúnen esta semana con las recientes
informaciones de más bombardeos y
ataques en Ucrania para el secretario
general de la otan James que es una
muestra de debilidad por parte de Rusia
Como por ejemplo estos bombardeos en
kiev de que las cosas no están
funcionando ni tampoco la invasión tal y
como planeaba en un principio Vladimir
Putin en la reunión que empezará mañana
los ministros de defensa hablarán de
entre otras cuestiones de Cómo proteger
infraestructuras críticas y sensibles
Como por ejemplo tras el Sabotaje de los
gasoductos nostrim 1 y 2 Asimismo el
secretario general de la otan también ha
anunciado de que va a haber ejercicios
militares de ilustración nuclear ya la
semana que viene un ejercicio militar
que ya está planeado antes de la
invasión pero que para el secretario
general de la otan es una muestra Clara
y firme de que la alianza estará
ayudando a sus socios siempre que sea
necesario